un monsieur bonjour un coeur nucléaire
c'est une première chirurgicale aux
états unis un malade a été dotée d'une
pile cardiaque un système classique mais
ce qui est nouveau donc
c'est l'alimentation de cette pile à
l'énergie nucléaire
l'avantagé essentielle réside dans le
temps de fonctionnement de cette pile 40
ans contre 10 actuellement
patrice veulent le nucléaire au service
de la vie un nouveau stimulateur pour
cet américain de 47 ans plus de soucis
pour son coeur avant trente ou quarante
ans la pilule magique fonctionne au
plutonium radioactifs elle produit une
double impulsion qui stimule les deux
parties du coeur un progrès car jusqu'à
présent la pile nucléaire ne pouvait pas
lier toutes les insuffisances cardiaques
c'est pourquoi dans les hôpitaux les
équipes médicales préféré le plus
souvent les piles classiques
leur seul défaut un remplacement
obligatoire tous les sept ou huit ans
avantage de ce nouveau stimulateur
nucléaire c'est qu'il durera au moins
aussi longtemps que l'espérance de vie
du patient
cela permet donc d'éviter aux malades
une opération chirurgicale
supplémentaire pour changer la pile et
ce procédé ne comporte aucun risque
puisque les radiations sont des affiches
ce nouveau pacemaker américain coûte
6000 dollars environ 36 mille francs
c'est 25% plus cher qu un pacemaker
classique mais un procédé rentable
puisque on évite ainsi toute nouvelle
opération sur le malade